es el momento clave del día del
armisticio el brillo de una llama bajo
el arco del triunfo
cerca de esta altamente simbólica tumba
aquí yace un soldado francés desconocido
caído durante la primera guerra mundial
y su tumba representa todos los
combatientes que murieron peleando por
francia a lo largo de la historia
el día del armisticio que celebra la
victoria de los aliados en la primera
guerra mundial y conmemora las batallas
y las vidas perdidas en ese conflicto
también honra desde 1912 a todos los
militares que han muerto defendiendo su
país
este año este tributo se ha enfocado en
un héroe de la segunda guerra mundial
huber charmaine un soldado de la
resistencia que estuvo entre los
primeros en unirse al general de gaulle
en 1940 él fue el último miembro de la
orden especial de la liberación
estos mil treinta y ocho hombres y
mujeres que se sacrificaron por su país
no desaparecen ellos han inscrito su
destino al lado de aquellos que llevaron
el espíritu de la resistencia el amor
por la patria libre los que rechazaron
la división apenas a los 20 años haber
germen se unió a de gaulle y libró
batallas fundamentales contra los nazis
y sus aliados llevando a la liberación
de francia
la vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris
se unió al tributo
leí sobre el que persona extraordinaria
tenía mucho fuego en su interior
jermaine descansará en mont valeriana
una locación que utilizaban los nazis
para ejecutar a los que se les oponían y
que hoy honra a esos luchadores por la
libertad